is there a reason why
i'm sure you guys could easily have put
your stuff in like zoomies and [ __ ]
yeah though they've they've offered it
like you guys are trying to keep it
exclusive
yeah we i mean it doesn't make sense for
our brand i mean i think that that's
like
that's part of it right if someone ever
goes completely commercial or sells out
they'll like
do that and then whoever buys the
company would put it into distribution
like that but for us our [ __ ] sells out
like i don't really want it to be
sitting in stores and
i don't know if it would really sit in
zoomies really so maybe i don't know we
just always turned it down
but damn you didn't tell me earlier give
me you told me how many how many people
were on your side at once but give me
like
what's what's the bit the biggest
clothing check in a month you guys have
cashed
i don't think i can say it it's a lot
yeah it's a lot of money the the thing
is though we're not
like we're definitely not balling it's
[ __ ]
we make a lot of money but like i mean
we have like 30 employees like
it's a [ __ ] business like there's a
lot of overhead
so much overhead and that's another
thing i've been looking into is just to
make us like
super profitable so we can i think right
now we're
um we're basically like funding like i
saying like the clothing line is funding
it's not going to get us rich it's
it's just funding all these big projects
to like get to that billion dollar
like icon that's we want to get to